[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'entretien de france 24 il est
considéré comme le héros de
l'indépendance de la république
démocratique du congo et son aura va
aujourd'hui même au delà des frontières
de ce pays patrice lumumba icône du
panafricanisme chef du premier
gouvernement congolais assassiné en 1961
avec la complicité de l'ancien
colonisateur la belgique à l'époque le
policier belge a chargé de faire
disparaître le corps avait récupéré une
dent qu'il a conservée pendant des
décennies avant que la justice belge ne
finisse par s'en saisir aujourd'hui
cette dent va être restituée enfin aux
descendants de patrice lumumba et j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui
roland lumumba fils de patrice lumumba
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur france 24 vous êtes
ici donc à bruxelles avec vos proches
avec vos frères et soeurs pour
recevoir cette relique de votre père
défunt des mains des autorités belges je
voudrais commencer cette interview par
vous demander votre sentiment qu'est ce
que cette restitution signifie pour vos
proches pour votre famille plus de 60
ans après l'assassinât de votre père
cette institution c'est quelque chose de
très important pour
on a commencé un deuil il ya 61 ans on
n'a pas clôturé nous sommes des
africains nous sommes de bons tours il
faut enterrer les morts pour que ce leur
âme reposante et quand quelqu'un est en
voyage et les très loin de sa terre si
l'ua les malheurs là où il est en plan
ses cheveux ses hommes quelque chose de
lui pour les faire parvenir dans sa
terre natale pour que son âme repose en
paix dont patrice du monde va enfin
pouvoir avoir une tombe en république
démocratique du congo on comprend à quel
point c'est important pour vous les
enfants elle les proches et qu'est ce
que ça signifie plus largement pour le
peuple congolais comment cette
restitution est perçue en république
démocratique du congo pour beaucoup
loubat c'est un mythe il a été déclaré
par différentes régime héros national
c'est un homme politique qu'il avait des
adversaires à son époque mais
aujourd'hui même ceux qui ne tient pas
que ne peuvent pas le dire ouvertement
ça veut dire il a une sorte d'unanimité
je crois qu'il ya un soulagement ce beau
coup que enfin il va se reposer en paix
j'imagine je ne sais pas dans la dent
lecteurs de chacun mais
en tant qu'africain tant que congolais
c'est quelque chose d'important il ya ce
soulagement cette joie du peuple
congolais malgré tout certains déplorent
le fait qu'il n'ait pas eu de test adn
sur sept dents est ce que finalement
c'est un problème que l'authenticité de
ce vestige ne repose que sur la parole
de ce policier belge qui avait récupéré
la dent en 1961 il y avait la difficulté
en ce qui concerne notre cas si on le
faisait ça les détruire la seule preuve
de son existence
mais avec les recoupements des toutes
les autres on a eu cette confirmation
donc on continue sur la logique
peut elle entre à la maison c'était
important pour vous de conserver ce
vestige avant tout on comprend bien
alors c'est c'est aussi la fin
finalement d'un litige qui a duré plus
de 60 ans mais il ya toujours une
instruction en cours à bruxelles depuis
une plante en déposer en 2011 par la
famille une instruction une enquête 1
sur l'assassinât de votre père il y à de
nombreuses zones d'ombré encore sur ce
qui s'est passé en 1961 qu'attendez-vous
de la justice belge
on attend la vérité on a droit à savoir
un des plus grands hommes
d l'afrique
que plus de 28 pays dans le monde l'ont
honorée
en donnant des désaveux né des places
des écoles des universités
comment éléments pourquoi éléments qui
l'a assassiné qui étaient impliqués
c'est important pour nous c'est
important pour que les générations
futures là pour en revenir à la justice
belge comment expliquer que la belgique
ait mis si longtemps à saisir la dent
puisque c'est arrivé en 2016 alors qu'il
était de notoriété publique que seb dont
se trouvait chez ce policier puisqu'il
avait exhibé à la télévision il l'avait
ramené en belgique comme un trophée j'ai
l'impression que à certains moments la
justice devait lier avec les actualités
politique je ne suis pas belge et donc
je me lève de commenter ce qui se passe
mais on est
toujours
à la recherche de cette vérité d'autant
qu'il n'y a plus que deux protagonistes
de cette affaire qui sont encore en vie
ici en belgique ils sont très âgés
évidemment
pourquoi à votre avis la tenue de ce
procès pendant si longtemps ce pas ils
étaient 10 15 ou 17 au départ et dans le
sud est deux on s'est passé
certaines personnes cherchent que ces
deux-là disparaissent et les dossiers
soit était d'office parce qu il n'y a
plus personne mais j'ose espérer qu
avant leur disparition que dossier cela
peloton
il ya aussi il faut le souligner les
réticences de la chambre des députés
puisque cette chambre des députés est
bien refuse de transmettre au parquet
fédéral les discussions de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire qui ont lieu à
huis clos est ce que pour vous c'est ça
pourrait être un signe d'une certaine
d'un certain manque de volonté des
autorités belges de faire la lumière sur
l'assassinât de votre père
l'exploitation du congo a pris fin
pétète d'une façon que
les honorables députés nul ne voulait
pas
que celles créées pour certains des des
problèmes
donc je comprends mais josé spirit et
plus de personnes devant aller dans le
sens dans le sens de la justice de ce
dossier vers
abouti à qu'on connaisse qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sur notre passé commun il ya
eu pendant
pendant longtemps une relation
pas bonne il faut assumer son histoire
vous nous avez exploité vous nous avez
fait des choses pas sympa le nôtre se
sont battus pour ça
ça fait partie de l'histoire on essaie
de clôturer
ce chapitre douloureux par cette
institution et l'enterrement mais ça ne
sera pas fini
on laisse ensemble le roi dernièrement
il était au courroux
probablement on considère qu'il a la
bonne volonté
d'aller de l'avant
dans les relations entre le royaume de
belgique le court mais pour aller de
l'avant il faut regarder ce qui s'est
passé et on se base 1,2 sur sa de voir
comment bâtir un futur mais en effet
derrière cette affaire il ya aussi
toute la douloureuse histoire de la
belgique à son ancienne colonie est-ce
que vous pensez que cette restitution
constitue une étape pour la belgique
dans un processus de
deux confrontations à son passé colonial
à je préfère dépenser ainsi que penser
combats continuent dans un bras de fer
en dehors d'être un fils biologique à
lumumba je suis un de ces millions des
fils
dans le sens de penser
quand il a demandé
l'indépendance la demande et qu'on passe
à une autre étape de relations égal à
égal
donc nous nous cherchons cette ouverture
de passer à une autre étape mais sans
oublier notre passé on doit chacun de
son côté assumé son passé pour pouvoir
bâtir quelque chose du plus haut dit
vous allez pas nous dire oublier
nous taper sur l'épaule a lancé ben ali
nous seule la mort peut pardonner et les
vivants n'ont pas le droit d'oublier
vous parlez de depardon récemment le roi
des belges s'est rendu en république
démocratique du congo il a réitéré ses
regrets pour la période coloniale pour
les souffrances subies pendant la
période coloniale mais certains membres
de la diaspora congolaise est ici en
belgique et certains congolais aimerait
plutôt des excuses qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
présentait des excuses ce serait pas
cher payé mais il a tout un pan allemand
à gérer ce que son pot ceux qui sont
contre ceux qui sont neutres moi je suis
pas belge je n'ai pas à m'arrêter
sur ce que je peux appeler détails pour
nous mais il faut manifester
concrètement
se régler ou ses excuses vrai qu'on
vienne rapidement sur le volet 10 hier
on a beaucoup parlé du volet belge mais
cet assassinat s'est fait en effet avec
la complicité de la belgique nous y
avait aussi d'autres pays occidentaux
notamment les états unis qui craignaient
la proximité de patrice lumumba avec
moscou est-ce que selon vous il faudrait
qu'ils aient qu'il y ait d'autres procès
que celui qui est ouvert enfin que
l'instruction qui est ouverte ici en
belgique bien sûr biais de
l'altitude dé l'histoire ce n'est pas
l'actualité de l'histoire des relations
belgo-congolaises nos et on veut savoir
tout ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ça
s'est passé qui a fait quoi ça nous
intéresse ce n'est pas parce que vous
étiez les grands méchants loups notre
colonisateur officielle qu'on n'a pas eu
d'autres prédateurs je vais terminer
avec cette question selon vous qu'est ce
qu'il reste aujourd'hui du lumumbisme sa
départ et à l'admiration à l'homme
uniquement pour chacun et à d'autres
cibles ils essaient de rentrer dans son
idéologie seule
vie politique tia sucrier un courant de
pensée ils en gagnent quelque chose
d'important au port merci beaucoup
roland mouret d'avoir accepté de
répondre aux questions de france 24
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]